welcome back to Long crime daily we
finish off in California where this week
Cain Velasquez walked out of the Santa
Clara County jail after posting his 1
million dollar bail Velasquez a former
UFC fighter had been behind bar since
February unattempted murder and other
charges prosecutors said he chased a
vehicle for 11 miles eventually firing
into it that car was carrying suspected
pedophile Harry gularte Velasquez claims
that gularte molested his four-year-old
son at a family-run daycare during the
chase gallarde's stepfather was shot but
he wasn't seriously hurt Velazquez was
released from jail around the same time
that a judge approved the case to go to
trial and it's likely to start next year
as Velasquez exited the jailhouse he
shared a few words
just thank you to everybody who had my
support
um I love all of you
um
yeah man just always continue to be
better as a person always do good things
um and yeah just make something positive
with this terrible situation you know my
family and I will
we're gonna do that
so Brian I understand you got a chance
to hear from Cain Velasquez's attorney
acclaimed attorney Mark garagos what are
his thoughts on the case yeah so
Velasquez is facing serious charges
attempted murder and other gun related
charges for attempting to shoot at the
man he believes that she assaulted his
son his four-year-old son now we got to
speak with attorney Mark garagos before
I get into that and what he says I think
and let me give you a little insight
into what I think he believes that he
could win this case with the right jury
and this is why when Velasquez what
Velasquez did was Reckless dangerous and
probably illegal but probably something
a lot of people would agree with this is
a father that many people are seeing is
protecting his four-year-old son this
would give garagos a lot of negotiating
power to get a better plea deal
especially with his client out and the
prosecution would know that it'd be very
hard to get 12 people to agree to follow
the law to a T and ignore the obvious
sexual assault in the room if it does go
to trial Gary goes has a strong argument
for Journal nullification it if not for
the whole case then maybe at least for
the attempt in Murder this could easily
also be a mistrial or a hung jury
because if one holdout says I'm not
going to find him guilty that ruins the
prosecution's entire case if you don't
believe me ask yourself what would you
let a father do to a man who sexually
assaults to their child
find 12 people to agree to the whole the
same thing now garigle seems to know
this too and you can hear it in his
interview
I I just don't see any indications that
this DA's or office has come to their
senses I you know the idea that they
were so adamantly and vigorously
fighting him going home to his family
when they know and they're the ones who
put out there originally the motive
behind all of this to me has been
stunning I mean how do you how do you
say that you're advocating for victims
when he's had the the allegations are
the most horrific that a parent can have
to live through
he's bailed out so everything changes
he's more likely to take this case to
trial without the pressure of making
this decision while incarcerated and so
if he picks the right jury he could
potentially win but there also sounds to
be a very strong and possible defense uh
heat of passion defense something that
any lawyer especially one in garago's
position with this client would love to
argue in court
Terry let's play this out a little bit
okay so if Velazquez is successful in
arguing as Brian just mentioned heat of
passion which is such an interesting
kind of Defense given the circumstances
here if he's convicted of that you think
it'll change the severity of the
sentence well you know it should Jesse
because it is a mitigating Factor heat
of passion means that you will provoked
by the victim and hear in any other case
this is definitely a provocation because
you have a father whose son was
allegedly sexually attacked by this
victim who you know basically he wasn't
shot but the other person was shot in in
the car so I think that if they can
argue that it was heat of passion he'll
go easy at the end of the day the judge
is going to go easy on him he's being
charged with 10 different counts assault
attempted murder and of course these gun
possession charges but I do think that
if they can prove this heat of passion
at the end of of the day even if he's
found guilty the sentencing will be a
lot easier he doesn't have any other
charges against him and I do think the
judge will take all of that into
consideration and give him a much lower
sentence having said that one thing I
will say Jesse I do think he should
serve some time we cannot have vigilante
justice like this and we have to send
that message I'll make a prediction
right here I think it's gonna be tough
to get a jury in this case that's a
subject for another day Brian Terry
thanks so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on Long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]